in this diagram we have two arcs
centered at Point P arc a B and you
could imagine this arc could be part of
a circle like this that is centered at
Point a B and then you have this larger
this arc CD that would be part of a
larger circle just like that centered at
Point P and we don't know the actual
angle measure of angle P right over here
but without even knowing that just
knowing the lengths of these of these
segments here I want to think about
whether we can figure out the ratio of
the length of Arc a B not angle a be the
length of Arc a B to the length of Arc
that in green the length of Arc the
length of Arc C D and I encourage you to
pause this video now and think about
this on your own well they didn't give
us the Radian measure here or there in
any type of angle measure here but let's
just imagine that it is X radians X
radians we've already seen that one way
to think about an angle measure in terms
of radians is that this is a count of
the number of of the length of the arc
that it intercepts in terms of radii so
this is if this has an angle measure of
X radians then that means that this arc
length is going to be x times the radius
it's going to be x radii long the radii
is 5 units long so this is going to be 5
let me do that in that yeah this is the
right color this is going to be 5x units
long well same argument for this arc
length right over here it has a radius
of 9 5 plus 4 and so this is going to be
X radii long each radius is 9 units so
it's going to be 9x units long so what's
the ratio of these two lengths well the
smaller a arc a B would have a length of
5 X arc CD would have a length of 9 X so
the ratio the ratio is the ratio is 5/2
now let's say someone says oh that was
pretty good you were able to figure out
this ratio let's say we were to give you
one of these lengths let's say that they
were to tell you that the length the
length of Arc a B let's say they tell
you it is 25 over 8
given that what else could you figure
out about it well you could actually
figure out everything else you would
want to know you could figure out the
angle measure in terms of radians and
you could figure out the arc length of
CED and I encourage you to pause the
video now and figure them out on your
own well let's work through each of them
this arc light we already figured out
that this art a B is length is 5x so we
could just say that 5x is going to be
equal to 25 over 8 divide both sides by
5 X is equal to 5 over 8 and so this the
measure of this angle right over here is
5 over 8 radians so what's going to be
the measure of this arc length so this
is going to be 9 times X that's just 45
over 8